it's a new year and what's the best
thing to do at the start of a new year
take a look behind you at the one you
just left so as was the case with 2014
in 2015 I did actually see enough movies
to comfortably do a top 10 list now I
didn't see everything I didn't even come
close but I did see pretty much all the
stuff that I really wanted to see but
this is hardly going to be a
comprehensive list is gonna be
subjective as heck this is just my
personal list for what I got around to
seeing let's get to it number 10
avengers age of ultron i did like
avengers age of ultron but ultimately it
does clock in as a bit of a
disappointment and ultimately it ends up
being one of those experiences that
after having seen it i can knit pick it
apart like nobody's business but
honestly while watching it i had a lot
of fun and there's a lot i enjoyed about
it and there's a lot of individual
elements that I really love I love James
Spader's Ultron villain I love the
entire climax of the movie and how they
prioritize getting the people to safety
for the dynamics between the characters
are about as good as they've ever been
the new characters were good and well
integrated I felt and the old characters
were back and good in a way they always
were the case of Hawkeye better than he
was last time just a good time all
around number 9 the peanuts movie you
know the term nostalgic gets used
generally in a fairly derogatory way
these days but I have to say that this
is nostalgic in the best possible sense
this is exactly what you remember about
Charlie Brown and peanuts TV specials it
doesn't mess with it it doesn't try and
reinvent it I mean it's a slightly
different visual style but this is
exactly what you remember and it gives
you that and if you enjoyed these things
all it's just it's just gonna hit you in
the right place at Maceo ah that's just
nice number 8 mr. Holmes this is the one
that I think flew under a lot of
people's radar probably because it got a
limited release but also probably
because I'm not sure people really
understood what they were getting into
going to see it because it does feature
Ian McKellen as a very elderly retired
Sherlock Holmes and it does feature you
know him sort of reeva
a case but it's not the Sherlock Holmes
mystery certainly not if your
introduction to Sherlock Holmes with
stuff like elementary or the BBC
sherlock series or the Robert Downey jr.
saw it's not any of those things this is
ultimately this is a meditation on aging
is what it is and it uses Sherlock
Holmes as a vehicle to tell that and
uses the audience's presumed familiarity
with that character as a way to sort of
demonstrate the difficulties of Aging
and for me it just hit me personally and
I found it to be very well done and very
powerful and very well paced and for me
the fact that it was Sherlock Holmes
there had that that little bit of
mystery going on made it sort of easier
to swallow because it was dealing it
deals with some heavy stuff that if
we're just hammering them too hard I I
probably would have resented the movie
for it but funneling it through Sherlock
Holmes made it more digestible but it
was still very powerful and certainly
for me although admittedly probably not
everybody's cup of tea number seven
Mission Impossible rogue nation this
might actually be my favorite Mission
Impossible will be and it really does
just take the best parts out of all the
previous movies because the thing about
the mission impossible franchises
because it's got a new director every
time the emphasis and what's good about
each entry tends to change film to film
so what this one did is it we got our
first bit of sort of legitimate
espionage that we've had really since
the first one from the third one it took
a really good villain because you know
most of these have not had great
villains and from the fourth film it
took the really big set pieces and the
wonderful stunts and from the second
helmet took nothing because the second
films suck you adding a really awesome
female character Tom Cruise still being
really good at doing this stuff Simon
Pegg being fun the action being well
shot and yeah this was just
well-executed adrenaline number six
Kingsman the Secret Service boy did this
one come out of nowhere it was kind of
on my radar because I really like the
director Matthew Vaughn he hasn't made a
bad movie yet and this just this is
james bond for the new generation and
and it's violent and it's funny and it's
vicious in its clever and it's
self-aware and a very unpretentious way
in the performances
all gray mica colin firth is an action
star who knew the main character is well
he was really good and and actually all
the young actors were really good in
Samuel Jackson was a little bit off but
in a really intriguing and fun way
everyone just seemed to really just be
having so much fun making this film and
it's one of those things where the fun
that they are having bleeds out and you
just get that same feeling watching it
and the fact that it's well executed on
top of all that yeah this is just a
great time number 5 inside out this is
pics are doing what they do best taking
an interesting idea and just diving into
it the best way that it can be done just
the little voices inside your head the
different emotions that you feel who's
in control who doesn't get along how
does the inside of your brain work not
on any sort of actual legitimate
neurological sense but like in a sort of
a psychological examination way and it's
really fun and it's really clever and
yeah yeah I'd teared up at a few point
if you've seen the movie you know what
part it was yeah yeah I did but you did
too don't you lie number for ex machina
I just really love the way this film
examined its questions of identity and
what it means to be human what it means
to be enslaved what it means to have
rights what it means to be property and
is looking at manipulation and human
nature and wonderful performances at the
hardest of the three main actors in this
are just phenomenal it is gorgeously
shot it's stunning that this was the
first movie that alex carlin actually
directly but this is directed so
assuredly and its really cleverly put
together in the way it's constructed
really very carefully elicits very
specific reactions from the audience and
I mean it's a think piece and it's a
little bit of a slow boil so if that
doesn't sound like your cup of tea
probably best to skip it but it's that
kind of thing intrigues you died would
absolutely say check this out now before
we get into the top three and the best
of this year I do want to pause for just
some quick words about some things that
didn't make this list in fact didn't
even
close I want to give a dishonorable
mention to my biggest disappointment of
the year which was Specter it it was not
the worst movie i saw this year but
considering the spectre was my second
most anticipated movie of 2015 that was
a really big disappointment however I do
want to give an extra-special
dishonorable mention to me and Earl and
the dying girl undoubtedly the worst
movie that I saw this year it was like
it's a checklist of all the worst quirky
indie cliches that you have ever seen I
don't have any heron hatred of cork you
want to see quirky done well sijui know
or see away we go those had characters
with quirks this was walking quirks that
they tried to pass off his characters I
really hated this movie let's get back
into positive territory and get to
number three Mad Max fury road boy you
know with all the remakes reboots
revisits that we get these days and so
many of them just being and some of them
being atrocious who would have thought
that so long since the previous Mad Max
that the original director who is not a
young guy anymore could just show up and
show everybody how to do this how action
is done how commentary is done in a way
that doesn't beat you over the head and
doesn't interrupt the movie and how just
letting the visuals tell the story
because I mean this is a rich world but
they don't stop and explain it you just
absorb it from everything that you see
and the performances are great Tom Hardy
is what max should be and of course
charlize theron is furiosa is just a
fantastic Eric tur and the whole I mean
it's really just just a two-hour chase
movie but man this thing does not quit
almost up to the top number two star
wars the force awakens now this thing
actually I knew was going to be on my
top 10 but it's been edging up higher
since I saw it a second time in the more
and more that I thought about it is it
on a technical level better than say mad
max fury road no it's not I can pick it
apart
more but honestly it just brought me
right back there and it cut through all
the cynicism that was left behind after
the prequels and the special editions
and all the BS I like the way the old
characters were used I love the new
characters I love the instant
camaraderie between Poe Dameron and finn
rey is a fantastic new lead I'm really
fascinated by kylo Ren I'm not gonna get
more detail than that because it's all
spoilery but I don't know why that's
stopping me everybody seen the movie by
now but it's it's great if you r star
wars for especially if you favor the
original trilogy this is what you wanted
now I don't say that derisive Lee I know
there are people generally younger but
there are people who like the prequels
or grew up on the prequels or prefer the
prequels and that's fine but speaking as
someone who grew up on the original
trilogy yeah this thing this this was
what I always wanted in terms of
continuation of the Star Wars story but
as much as I enjoy Star Wars The Force
awakens it does not take the top spot
the top spot was a movie I expected to
like I would never call that I would
like it as much as I do though and that
is the Martian Ridley Scott you can
still make a truly legitimately good
move good movie heck great movie with a
wonderful central performance from Matt
Damon but every single performance in
this movie is terrific everyone's
bringing their a-game and really that's
what makes this will be so good it's
just everyone who took part in it Ridley
Scott Drew Goddard who wrote the script
the cast the crew cinematography
everything everyone is just doing their
job exactly as it needs to be done
nobody's doing half measures everybody's
on their a game and we just end up with
this terrific tight product I swear this
thing was scientifically calculated
almost to the second because a it we'd
be on earth watching you know the
group's they're trying to figure out how
to get him home and and i would get just
the slightest hint of a tingle of the
thought of i kinda wonder what's going
on with Matt Damon on Mars right now and
I swear to God and the instant I even
had the hint of that thought it cuts to
him again and then spends the exact
amount of time that I needed with him
before going back again just this thing
is so tight and so wonderfully put
together and it is my favorite movie of
2015 I have to say it it has been a
pretty good year overall as far as
movies go at least for the ones that I
saw but what about you what was your
favorite movie of 2015 or if you want to
give me a whole top 10 feel free to put
something down in the comments whatever
it is go ahead and let me know feel free
to like subscribe follow me on twitter
at council of geeks and also check out
the council of weeks podcast yeah the
play of this stuff is going to become
standard on this thing and i'll put
links to all the other stuff that I've
got going on in the description of this
video so until next time this council is
adjourned